I like it that's my first stars it was
definitely intense my heart was beating
kind of fast a couple times once we got
the hard level to us it was challenges
good good what an awesome time I was
playing with this guess you have to work
as a team if you don't work as a team
you know you're not going to accomplish
the mission we weren't talking a lot
we added a person she was communicating
us through it all and we and we got a
victory so it was dope I'll say I'm more
of an attacker I think book have their
advantages but I personally like like
getting in there and being on the
offense defending is this kind of tough
but they come in through
every window yeah the different
characters had unique feel to the game
to allow players to express their
plumbing pipes I like the brute he's
basically big boy hammer shotgun clean
you know yeah I'll call my favorite
character every time he Ashley my
favorite she was able just to maneuver
well you never really see a girl
character so I like that part I got four
daughters I'm gonna pick it up when it
comes out so you're looking forward to
it let's exchange gamertag so we can do
that oh yeah no doubt i'll be buying
rainbows any competitive environment
whether it is from screen or on the
field this game has it just like the
cycle of others
you